Olivia Wilde goes to hell do you want to
know how I was watching this movie next
to a couple who wouldn't shut the [ __ ]
up in the movie theater and like three
drunken douchebags on this side of me
who wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up either
hell I've been there it's scary the
Lazarus effect so the Lazarus effect is
a horror movie that cost 10 bucks to
make so if it makes 15 bucks this
weekend profit this one stars olivia
wilde donald glover looks silver from
x-men Days of Future past one of the
chicks from Once Upon a Time and some
other dude and long story short they're
doing experiments with the serum that
might bring people back to life Olivia
Wilde gets shocked and dies in the labs
of the like we need to do it then she
comes back but did she really come back
she starts acting really creepy and
you're like lose it like some demon that
came back from Hell what I like about
this movie we're gonna get the positives
out of the way first it does have some
creepy imagery in horror movies let's
face it you've seen it all before and a
couple of jump-scares happen I'm like uh
all right guys I'm gonna I've seen this
[ __ ] before
some creepy imagery starts happening I'm
not even going to say what it is because
I don't want to ruin it for the people
who might against a better judgement be
like you know what I want to watch that
movie this weekend some of the camera
angles you know the shining the
flashlight the cameras with the
flashlight and I was like that's that's
like HD Resident Evil [ __ ] and I liked
the fact the debate happens in the movie
was like oh when you dies it just
chemicals in your brain that makes you
see the white light or do you go to
heaven in that the movie has you
wondering is she possessed by some demon
does she go to hell and a demon
possessed her or is it science is it
like she's unlocking her brain so she's
like a really messed-up version of Lucy
that's what I'm here to tell you guys
that ultimately I felt like I was
watching a horror version of Lucy and at
that point the movies kind of a mess
when things are happening and the horror
things are happening you're entertained
for what it is and then the movie tries
to be some pseudo intellectual [ __ ]
it's not like it tries to give you
enough information to have you decide
what's going on it gives you straight-up
conflicting information you're like I
movie doesn't know where it wants to go
doesn't know what it wants to do just it
knows that it wants to be a horror movie
sure I mean ultimately the plot is silly
than I am supposed to be in this lab
there's no way they're gonna break into
this lab and do these experiments but
they do which is why movies should not
give you that thing that thing that tear
that makes you go away you know what
maybe I can just peel this apart a
little more you start deconstructing one
thing it just quickly
unravels like pulling at that thread in
his shirt and then soon you're like oh
crap I just ruined it the acting is
functional the dude who plays
Quicksilver he had a couple of really
good lines where you know he's the comic
relief in the movie then the movie
starts wrapping up and by the end of the
movie the end of this movie reminded me
of the end of the movie the call have
you remember that seriously man I was
like this is just giving you [ __ ] for
the sake of giving you [ __ ] so something
can happen so it can cut two credits in
the end guys the Lazarus effect is more
or less what you think it's going to be
it's going to be a horror movie with
some jump scares for sure not going to
say they're not in the movie but there
are only a couple of them the imagery
was actually really cool you can tell
the director wanted to legitimately be
scary and there's some cool parts a
couple of hair-raising moments I'm not
gonna say it wasn't affected but was it
good no it's still a messy movie that's
the bummer cuz with where it looks like
the director was going in the movie it
looks like it could have been that
horror movie that made you walk out of
the movie theater and go holy God guys
you tell all your friend you're like
it's actually way better than you think
it's gonna be the Lazarus effect is
still gonna be a good time if you're
drunk
ya know it's a party or so was she
possessed by a demon or was she just
really evil Lucy or maybe demon juice a
100% or Falkenberg
close intense I said the Lazarus effect
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more